now [ __ ] pay is there of shower
thinking is going to explain you how
marketing is evolving thanks to data
science is a technical engineering so
welcome
give him a warm applause please thank
you very much can you hear me properly
yes ok good ok so I hope that we are
going to have some fun here and I'm
telecommunication engineer this is my
technical background although many years
ago I began working for for marketing so
real marketing is my my patient I've
been working for multinational companies
like in the consumer market like
Starbucks or intent at Damien in the
payment like Sony Pictures or in pharma
like Novartis and many others in you can
also find one of the books I wrote in
Amazon which is called latter Belinda's
lettuce is a bikini Spanish which is
about the agile practices in marketing
so I'll just begin this presentation how
many of you are working in marketing
would you raise your hand
ok give I was happy to be the only one
here but anyway
why he we marketing we are so far away
from the data science guys which said I
cannot show that we have indeed in the
agency saying that which is the approach
to the work that the different people do
same like when a libel is broken the
front-end developer just paintings in
jell-o's and says to the back-end
developer okay it is no works but only
during the day of course the data
science he analyzes the bull market
price against the probability of
of a failure interest to the developer
organics and saying waste for fraks for
her pics while as the marketing guys I
think that we are much more smart and
basically combines to convince you that
the dart eaten new jello in the new life
in come back to her to play candy crush
will really love candy crush you know
just to be a little bit more studios a
the market in the market value for
marketing is huge with something
consultant company company like he did
IBC is saying that he is 1.2 trillion
dollars in which is also more important
is that is growing at an average this
market almost to a 20 percent something
like 70 17 percent a per year and
release at the core of the needs for the
companies they didn't the main focus on
the companies is obviously trying to
obtain new customers
this gentleman called McCain John Monica
said already almost 100 years ago a
sentence which is true in marketing used
to be true in marketing saying that all
the money I spend in advertising is
worst the trouble is I don't know which
would have and it's probably happening I
would say that even more for our the
digital advertising or traditional
advertising that we use in internet a
decision and study that shows the ad
block penetration basically you know the
a block is the configuration that you
use in the your browser just to limit
the the advertising so something like a
cool happen that 25% for all the
advertising using Internet is never seen
what's happening here if I think myself
about
the way I approach to buying a product
like for example a car like ten years
ago eight years ago it's completely
different that they would be we'd with
today ten years ago there was a seller
you know with a nice street and he
decided to which is the information I
worship which is the model I will
purchase he was really the person
deciding all the customer coming to the
shop what they will be more or less the
decision but if cleaning has absolutely
changed and now obviously if I go to buy
a car I have already taken my opinion
and even take my decision and just go to
the shop just to make the financial
stuff you know or just to finalize the
transaction the point is that we we no
longer need this traditional stage guys
this is in the consumer might mine has
happened has already happened if the
budget journey has v furna a generic
approach controlled by the buyer by the
seller to add self kuiper I want to take
my decisions and this is happening
across all the different industries in a
power by the buyer for a very long long
time the majority of the customer the
buyers journey but most control by the
by the seller and they this is very
important that saying that something
like the eighty five of the effort for
the companies the marketing effort must
put on the side of the other cycle from
the Warner's consideration to decision
in a very few time just the the last
year's a
this is going like in the opposite side
a garnet garnet a customer submit is
saying like buy in three years something
like an eighty five percent of the of
this trouble will take place from the
buyers without talking to their human
version so this basically changed and I
going to to link different concept
now therefore that the companies need to
make me in need to do is it on the side
of the businesses decision what is
happening here is that all this
information need to be considered by the
companies before they have all this
information but now the marketing
department we need the data science guys
because all this information all this by
the cycle is not taking inside the
company is taking outside the company
probably way through the internet or
browsing staff or using Internet to make
big decisions
a new era year requires a different
approach this is more or less how we
split the different moments through them
marketing than the marketing strategy
beginning with the traditional mass
marketing like the data be combined to a
more segmented marketing the relational
marketing and now we are in the moment
for the people personalized marketing we
as consumers with an effete anymore the
advertising we want the companies to
provide us more meaningful in attractive
and interesting stuff for us just in
this moment in the future which is a
predicted
in a very few years something like 3 G's
this predatory marketing in the
artificial intelligence and will be will
be coming my personal opinion is that
all this predicate marketing is a much
more closer because it's bringing a lot
of value to the to the companies with a
pretty big marketing approach we are
speaking that we are saying that we need
to take a work in in a different way the
first point is just to take a different
approach to decisions during a lot of
time the marketing department have been
taking decision based based on the
experience for the for the marketing
director or the strategies in strategies
in this department this is an study from
the MIP what is basically saying that
the data driving marketing produces a a
completely different and more powerful
powerful result listening study for a
telecommunication company we decided to
launch some plans the marketing on one
side a marketing department decided
which are the updates segment to learn
to this plan on the other side a wall
basically are a data team decided on
based on 304 different features which
are the best plan for each of the
customers and this data that driving a
approach
absolutive leads to a commission rate 13
times better so in this moment we are
already having a lot of information it's
time for this marketing departments to
make these decisions bins based on this
idea I'll leave you here this link
for for this study we also need
different technologies for me has been a
complete discover for what is an item in
a especially specifically what does is
they the Jupiter platform is a platform
where you can maintain obviously a
personal history where you can serve all
your data or your graphical data it's a
perfect platform for gathering different
information from different tools that
you were using in digital marketing like
Jupiter but it's also a tool that we can
use a to interact with customers with a
marketing automation april's is really
the the glue and this is a new these new
tools there are a veil for working in
what is more important what is coming
now is the artificial intelligence and
the predicate marketing I didn't want to
live on a speech just a strategic speech
or general purpose split but I bring in
some a small demonstration about what is
a what can information a can now have a
company from the customers this is a
basic demo explaining how one company
can segment this the customers based on
these new tools and using IBM Watson
which you know it's not the open-source
but it is where term you know also many
other training modules you can use in
specific inside IBM Watson we are using
personality inside which is a brilliant
in an IP I and a connection where once
you have information from the customer
this person has been sighs predict which
is the a customer personality super
abilities by different groups we are
going to see now in real-time the
consumption consumption preferences how
consumers have roads are buying decision
the tone analyzer you probably have been
working on you know already a lot about
this a tone analyzer basically how they
feel or what they are saying about the
avatars in a Watson NLU which is a
natural language understanding analyst
uh Nelson keywords topics about what
they are speaking about so I and it
first to apologize because we are just
ending this moment during a maintenance
window really piss me off you should not
be doing this this presentation on
Sunday I I think what anyway let's try a
please bear with me I will try to do to
do my best okay so this is an
environment that you probably know very
well dupa dupa and network okay in
here's the moment that where we are
getting the the information from the
customers this is a information
gathering for different information from
certain media from in interviews and
also from a one a Content contact center
from one customer in for this demo we're
getting an a small number of of a
customer which is the number is 30 50
customers sorry can you make it bigger
please sorry a little your desk
thank you
no okay okay good
not so big okay I think that I hope yeah
it's better and basically in this moment
what we are going to do is sin we are
sending all this information I don't
know what's happening here we are
sending all this information to Watson I
don't know if they entered Internet
I know if it was going to have to happen
[Music]
well I don't I'm not going to wait more
because I don't know what's happening
here
anyway I have my have prepared myself
but we are getting to date data frames
one is a about the personality from this
customers it gives you back a 47
different features about which is the
personality for this customers each one
more information about how they infer
this really a huge work that the guys
there at IBM are doing here and you can
have internet you can see help they're
always defending information the police
that you have here something like 47
different features they are between zero
and one values and also they the
consumption preference we are taking for
for this work something like twelve
different features that we considered a
they were appropriate for this project
and we are taking features like the
sensitivity of the customer this is a
prediction all values are between one
and zero the sensitivity of the
ownership of for buying a optima buys
the likely to
for quality when buying clothes they
likely to prefer style they likely to
prefer comfort for from buying clothes
and we gather all this information in in
a single data FRA data frame defining
every customer in this tab okay so now
is it working something that could be
very basic for you but for us for the
marketing in guys mix is a game changer
why because fron all this information we
are making with is clear and we are
making clusters this used to be
traditionally by marketing department
saying okay because these are the young
people in in between our customers this
will be group a this way there are the
old ones they are the Millennials and
this has all this other stuff
do not dismiss approach having this kind
of information no longer worse basically
what we are doing here is that a once we
have all this information coming from
Watson what we are doing I hope that we
got the I know I know was not going to
work anyway here I met my my slide well
we are what we are doing here we are
automatically or we are on with the
oldest data we are a cluster in this
segment this used to be as I said before
based on they could feel good feeling
from the marketing departments now it is
a way to cluster jeweler customer based
on all this information
going to continue here when we are
testing customers based on their
consumer preferences for example you see
some pieces an error bars saying a which
are how are they a segmented they say
this a miss customers in also inside
each of the clusters we are seeing how a
all this group of a consumers how they
approach the buying pigeons this is a
general view if these customers are
likely to be inflow influences by social
media this is the this point here in
which is they they they approach to
Atkins a consumer to a buying process
based on these different groups that we
we made the clusters before let me see
if I can have this information
[Music]
yeah this is the representation from
different clusters you know we've been
using PCA to to make this a
representation for this matrix with a
something like 17 beacon features in
order to represent the the customers and
these are the different values for the
whole group and based on each of the
different clusters in this this matrix
represent also their personality for
each of the different segments we have
to hear information that for a marketing
department is really like gold because
is saying to you how do you need to
approach this customers if you have
information about buying products but
also about their personality for example
this is about practicality some of them
will have will be more meaningful or
less meaningful if this this group of
customers which is the level of
curiosity that they have with us
bhutanese the consciousness which is the
activity they intellect be amongst
emotionality which is also very
important in in the marketing for a
marketing basically we are getting how
they approach a buying decision and also
how which is their personality where do
you see more information this is divided
just the same information divided by by
groups and to switch again sorry to
switching from one on the other but no
sign of they are not going to work
and I know going to to to make also this
demo this the second request that I was
trying to do with a with a what somebody
seemed that something is not working
it's an a tone analyzer we also know in
this moment for this consumer how they
feel if they feel anger with us with
goods to deliver feel joy of the feel a
sadness and also uh the third
information that the level of
information that we are getting from
this cutting these customers and is
about what are they speaking about we
which are the main a interest and
undivided by by by group these are so
giving us a lot of more and more
information about how to make this
marketing approach to our customers
now with this kind of information a is
the moment to provide a deeper
personalized marketing campaigns or
marketing strategies to our customers
it's no longer needed to have a
traditional marketing a approaches
possible to a personalized which is the
the landing page the website experience
the product recommendation the personals
offers that we can provide a to discuss
so at the end we are getting into the
point to explain what is a marketing
data science the the one of the most
important part for me is that is a data
driving marketing as we said before
instead instead of taking decisions
based on the experience this approach no
longer has worked because we have all
this information about our customers and
we have all this huge amount of features
you know that has been studied at the
human brain a probably can only
correlate up to five different variables
and with all this information is not a
is not feasible for a human being to
make this decision isn't about the a
artificial intelligence in marketing use
the the tools that we have now in the
marketing of about artificial
intelligence and also predict which are
the the the results that our customers
will take it's about the inducing as we
are seen in this demo a data science
tools have been developed for all the
right areas
most of them for a big data analysis is
using this information for small data
analysis a lot of companies have small
that have problems instead of these big
data problems hmm is integrating data
scientist sites and technology inside
the marketing division and basically
this is why we the big eyes marketing
needs you guys the the data the data
science to help us taking this and this
what is the what is happening which is
the digital transformation for the for
the companies but here's for me some of
the points more more important is
understanding a customers in a new way
in a new way you say the point
understanding that the companies need to
see and understand and check and and
really care about what the customer
needs it is creating a more sustainable
marketing instead of the traditional
advertising approach saying okay I have
this message
let's use the the digital marketing or
the let's use a television let you stay
the radio to spread my message
it's creating a more sustainable
marketing because I'm personalizing the
message for each of my customers in its
mode in the appropriate mode a moment in
is about providing the customer with a
more personalized experience
what I say here is that the digital
marketing that and in data science needs
to be aligned as I said before in order
to better I understand as a consumer
needs the digital marketing the the
marketing guys also need some kind of
improve their analysis and data science
skills in adversity and expertise
and for me also data science in the
coming years will be a central part for
all the digital marketing project not
only they the technology is important
the business strategy of course is
important the content marketing how we
approach our customers is important but
the marketing data science is the core
is Denny way where we will take these
decisions and basically they said I
wanted to twist play more or less which
is this new approach and they know all
those you know since the day the
technology is not play with me but try
to explain how we are in in in companies
trying to approach this the new market
[Applause]
any questions
thanks for a talk a parasite understood
you're using what's right yes we are
using IBM Watson with just some a month
ago they provided this digital which
makes this a very they provided an
Watson analytics which is an analytics
tool and also the Watson APA they have
encapsulate this is a cognitive system
which is an artifical intelligence which
provides you very firm it for me is a
very easy way to access this information
but otherwise you know you know we'll
need to deployed your your system which
will be really very complicated yes I
only use what Sunnah I think also is
very user-friendly so my question is do
you think in the future the companies
are going to directly use Watson instead
of out sorting your your services for
example I don't know if I understand I
mean for example I don't remember you
said something that the pharma company I
don't remember the name okay imagine
that the if Watson is such a user
friendly to you think in the future
maybe not now but in two years three
years something like that
varieties of the pharma companies going
directly to use Watson with the day with
their data instead of outsourcing or
contracting your services yeah okay
thank you burn testing a question in
complicated M I think that for us we
have been working something a month with
a Watson in for me my experience is that
I want to think like Watson is someone
else
well someone more in the team is not
someone that is going to replace a human
providing you with more insight which is
the the one of the most important part
for for Watson in and so forth for data
science in in in general is the Elson of
bias you know if we are we make a
president Macri Dean is kind of a
studies are making through focus groups
you know you cut some people in a room
and begin asking them how do you feel
about this new coca-cola or this new
stuff or this new stuff
you know but at the end this an human is
part which is making this decision in
any space on this guy you know what is
providing us a pools like Watson is for
marketing guys together with data
science anyway way for approaching this
question this business questions but
with data so for me is not a replacement
I think that a lot of companies will
need through an agency or internally or
whatever it is our different approach or
or combined you know I think that
probably there are more people here
working in consultancy and what way the
companies also very important and I
think that the Congress is also a key
important there is a lack of knowledge
with a huge huge app you know in in
training for all these people and no
matters how how the company decided to
make this decision but NIST we taking
you know but because the consumers have
this information already as you know and
they need to take benefit from these
motivations
- sastra at all very interesting and
what is the the perception the feeling
of the companies that you have
approached with this strategy
do you still okay to use machine
learning in in such decisions they fail
skirt surprise they don't care I think
something like 60% for the work we are
doing is not non-technical what the
formative we are planing them that what
they have they they are very happy this
data there at the beginning they are
really genomic mind-blowing support for
this department traditional offline
departments or traditional part and say
I didn't know we can get this which is
incredible joy and how we can
personalize this all this information up
now understand that we are not getting
good results it is absolutely impossible
you know and now it they are beginning
to understand more and more how it's how
it's working
this is also one point of I would say
scary there's really very powerful tools
and we really need to think about which
is the best way because where as you see
we are taking the personal even the
personality you know further for the for
the customers and with big power comes
also the big of responsible Vista so
they are basically obviously we are just
in the beginning you know for all this
stuff and I think that they are at the
beginning that they they say jinan this
job and I think in in Joe as we said
just dropping you know I didn't know
what we can we can give it identify I
properly respond to okay thanks more
questions
so are you saying that they will so in
fact now you are combining at this
method of surviving on asking consumers
about what they prefer you are combining
active with passive so getting
information with from this place so the
way they buy through internet you are
good yeah I'm very going together yes
you the question is which is our
approach to make new studies yeah but in
the future do you think that will
persist both approaches or just the
passive methods will will be replacing
the active ones that the ones that are
you asking you what are you going to do
you're asking the right question to the
wrong loop guy yeah because I'm very
technical engineer and I would say
everything with the data you know it's
my vision and it's like my board you
know is and I think that the
misinformation is I no longer see a
marketing expert taking this kind of
decisions because the bucket have
changed so much during last eight years
you know this millennium stuff no one
has this experience if the market is
more or less stable and human expert can
take these decisions at least from from
this is my personal views you know but
with all the change that we see you know
the car scrolling three years are going
to self-driving this will change
everything so no human will take a
prepetition and these tools will be at
this moment will be a help
as I said before it's like someone more
in the team you helping to make
decisions not taking the deficiency self
but helping the marketing guys to make
the decision
hi I have two questions very quickly
could you tell us a little bit more
about that I nest your non-collision for
example I think that thing one is light
you mention Google Earth but I don't
know if you are planning to use Twitter
something like that in order to make
more accurate as to this and the second
one this if you follow some kind of ID
I'll approach with your customer name
with you
first of all give to them a prototype
and you're still iterating with them in
order to add more sources and more
analytics and advancing in the in the
final report okay very good questions
and the first ones about the the sources
and of course Twitter and depending on
the on the customer LinkedIn have a
really a lot of information probably
better in linking because that you write
your profile in you have you can know a
lot the personality from the from the
customers but also in just in we also
mix different sources like interviews
and in Vista M they are so another tool
which is marketing automation tools
which basically and once you enter one
side you know all this stuff about
cookies there will be tracking tracking
you and saying okay this guy like this
is content and this content and he has
intro interest he's interested I love
this this proposal or or this content so
this is because Jupiter is is so
powerful job because you need to
integrate many many different stuff
together
also coming as you say before with
approach how they are coming to us which
are their initial interest yeah and this
is making this Mattox for
basically abiding projects about youth
seekers with second question is the
about agile em in order to implement
this is a new way of working you know in
order to implement a this dis approach
saying okay stop doing all the stuff you
are doing now I begin making all this
stuff from now it's impossible no one is
not working and as you said before and
the agile approach trying to take these
quick wins kind of residue can take
everything from the beginning you need
to take very small steps in order to
improve it so absolutely this is what we
I think that that is really the only way
and what is one of the the keys for me
besides I operates to implement this
data science project okay there's time
two more questions you have more okay so
well thank you very much okay okay
[Applause]